kayla anderson
first and foremost a washington state
coug all right
she's going to join us
right now talking to us all about the
titans kayla
how are you doing
my fellow coug i'm doing well gentlemen
i hope you're doing well hey kevin i'm
ready to rock this let's talk some
football all right
so
tennessee gets the buy number one
overall seed first five loss team to
have a number one overall seed since
like 2002 but
with all that goes into super wild card
weekend it seems like a lot of people
just they weren't talking about the
titans so people have kind of forgotten
about them but they're the best team in
the afc they're getting arguably the
best running back in the world back to
play
why are people not talking more about
this tennessee titans team right now
yeah and i can really speak to that
being on the local level you know and
being a reporter here covering the team
day in and day out
look nashville tennessee is the hot spot
if you want to come party if you want to
go to a hockey talk if you want to come
listen to country music and it's
becoming a really big sports city as
well but when it comes to the titans and
just the national respect
it's just not there yet and they've been
to a super bowl but they haven't won it
and so i think it's just something until
you prove it
maybe they're not going to get that
respect that they deserve
but being a person who's covered them in
and out this season through ups and
downs and adversity and playing 91
different players it's a team that has
clearly earned this number one seat in
the afc and at times it's not looked
great and i think that's why another
reason you look at maybe you're not
getting the national respect because
they have losses to the jets they have
losses to the houston texans but you
know they've also got some great wins
against kansas city against the bills
against the la rams and so if you're an
outsider looking in that's maybe the
reason why this isn't the team jumping
off the page at you statistically
they're not the team jumping off the
page but when you look at what they've
gone through this season and how they've
gotten it done and how they arrived at
this spot you've got to give them
respect yeah you do i mean flat out
first game out
after the derrick henry injury uh is at
la on a sunday night and they thoroughly
dominated this defense led by kevin
byard has been a dominating force
they've gotten pressure up front what's
been the difference
in the maturation of this defense and
how they were able to solidify and kind
of bring this team along when they
needed them mid-season
yeah that's a great question ryan
because when you look at the defense
last year it was a complete dumpster
fire
the word communication that we had to
use in our press game conferences
because there was none it was just
mind-blowing and every time we would ask
about what went wrong or why they were
so bad on third down
they didn't know i mean it was just all
over a mess and at the time you know you
didn't really know what was going on in
terms of who was running the defense
because they had not named shane bowen
the defensive coordinator they were
saying he was calling the plays but he
was not the defensive coordinator with
the title
this year i think what happened is from
training camp
you kind of felt
what this defense wanted to do how it
wanted to set the tone this season
because they were flat out embarrassed
by how historically bad they were last
year third downs was historically bad
for this tennessee titans team um when
it comes to overall numbers and so you
could feel like the the drive that they
had and you know they named shane bowen
defensive coordinator
they also made some really money off
season moves and vic beasley and david
clowney did not work out the year before
and this year they went and got bud
dupree and deniko autry and to me that
was the biggest difference for this
defensive front because when you get
pieces that complement the other guys
that are already on the line like
jeffrey simmons who is the second team
all pro this year and harold landry
who has been pretty good for us for the
most part since arriving in tennessee
when you get the whole line that
complements each other and does it with
just four guys
that has been the complete difference
maker
they've been able to get pressure on the
quarterbacks they've been able to
you know generate saks this year
something that they couldn't do at all
last year and that really takes a lot of
pressure off the secondary and allows
guys like kevin bayer to do what he does
best which is you know
talking down the ball and he's having a
pro bowl season obviously so that has
been the biggest difference is really
getting the right pieces up front that
all complement each other we're talking
with kayla anderson wkrn nashville
sports anchor there covering the
tennessee titans on a daily basis all
right uh also the injuries right aj
brown's injury julio jones's injury
has continued to placate that football
team
all year long derek henry being out but
seemingly it feels like all three
are as healthy as they've been maybe
this year tell us a little bit about
where they're at and what you expect
from them this weekend
yeah what's been crazy is last year you
saw what that offense did right it was a
machine and they put up some really good
numbers they were really hot in the red
zone
but this year
where you thought it might be the same
or even better with the addition of
julio jones and having aj brown and
having derrick henry it was completely
the opposite and that's because it was
just injury after injury after injury
and you really do have to give them a
lot of credit for what they've been able
to hold up this entire time when losing
derrick henry going in and getting backs
that fit your system and deonte foremans
come in and fit right in and he's he's
put up pretty good numbers they've been
able to continue to really um base
everything off the run game ryan
tannehill's numbers aren't off the page
but he manages everything extremely well
and the biggest thing is his players
respect him and look at him as a leader
of that team now with saying that they
got healthy at the right time they're
getting all their pieces back for the
playoffs and that means also you're
enjoying a bye week that they had a
little bit more rest
derek henry spoke today for the first
time since
pretty much before the injury
and you could just tell how hungry this
guy is i've covered a lot of athletes in
my career and this guy is something
special
it's not just because he can go out
there and put up numbers it's something
that he brings to this team and all his
teammates talk about it it's just a
presence on the field that he has but
also he is that home run hitter right i
mean he can change a game he can change
the momentum of a game with one run and
so he's back he's healthy um he has not
been activated obviously yet but we're
expecting that to happen in the next
couple of days they wouldn't allow him
to talk if that wasn't the case right so
he he's definitely ready to go he was in
full patch yesterday going you know
hitting other guys and you looked great
and then aj brown also a guy that has
dealt with some injuries this year but
his back is healthy and julio jones has
been i guess the big question mark for
this team they expected more out of him
but when it comes down to him
if he can perform in the postseason then
it was worth getting that guy here and
right now he is healthy that hamstring
seems to be fine because he's not going
to go out there and and maybe put up a
ton of yards or be the number one guy
but he's going to make some big plays
when you need it to go downfield and i
think that having all those pieces going
at the same time in a healthy offensive
line maybe they can start to get this
offense going in the right direction
you made reference to the 91 players
that have suited up and played for this
football team this year i had a few
concerns with the bye week with guys
coming back off injuries julio jones and
pieces being put into place derek henry
having not played forever and all of a
sudden being asked
to carry the load for this football team
and if that could backfire on them how
do you feel about that players that
haven't played that much and now are
going to be expected to do a lot in a
playoff game against a very capable and
quality opponent in the cincinnati
bengals what's your thought process
around that or is that just something
that's you know that's the way it is
here in tennessee this year we're going
to play as whoever can play is going to
play and we're going to play the best we
can
yeah and i think that's a fair question
because whenever you have guys coming
off of you know ir or just guys that
have been banged up all year i i think
it's you don't know exactly what you're
going to get especially when you ramping
it up to another level in the postseason
i mean that's just different play that's
playoff football um what i will say
about derek henry specifically because
that's the guy we're all looking at
right we all don't really know what to
expect out of him and he admitted today
that this is the first major injury he's
ever had to deal with in his career
and so you've got to be thinking you
know first and foremost mentally is he
ready to go and then physically
he seems fine but i don't i don't
necessarily think they're gonna just
throw him out there um i could see them
potentially getting him you know 15 to
20 carries at some point of the game i
think they'll start to ramp it up if
they need to but you got those other
backs you can rely on too so it's not
going to be all pressure on derek henry
which is a good thing because in a way
you just have to see how he reacts in
game action um but mike brabel is a guy
who he's a dog like he he you look at
his career i mean he competed his butt
off he grinded and that's what he
expects his players to do and he's going
to protect them but he's also going to
let them go out there if they feel good
and do what they need to do
and a guy like julio jones he's been
kind of resting on and off throughout
the season with that hamstring injury
i know that's a guy that they definitely
monitor and you know use in certain
situations um i think he has a lot to
say with some of the things too so i
think he's going to be a full go go and
nothing will be you know held back in
that regard and same with aj brown this
guy is somebody who just loves to
compete
this is this is a team that's based off
of their their head coach's identity
right so they're going to put those guys
out in the field they're going to work
them
all right before we get you out of here
we're speaking with kayla anderson wkrn
nashville sports anchor um covers the
tennessee titans as good as anybody
what um
why do you think
that this titan's team is being
overlooked i i have some theories maybe
not maybe it's not because you don't
have the the prolific quarterback
why do you think people are looking past
the number one seeded tennessee titans
heading into this weekend
i think first and foremost you look at
the other teams in the afc
and you look at what the kansas city
chiefs and the buffalo bills have done
here recently
especially in the last
games that they had and you're like whoa
okay these are legit teams like what the
buffalo bills did it just was incredible
the other night and kansas city looked
pretty darn good as well and i think any
time you're you're kind of put in the
category with teams like that who have
quarterbacks
that are always talked about that really
are relied on and are a reason why the
team goes as it goes is because of those
quarterbacks and then you look at the
titans and nothing against ryan
tannehill he's been actually really
solid for the titans since arriving here
and taking over when when mariota was
benched um
i think that's the first and foremost
thing the quarterbacks run this league
ryan you know that's your former
quarterback right i mean you're that's
going to get the attention um so i think
that's a reason and also i just don't
think the titans did enough on offense
consistently this year they didn't put
up the numbers to look at them like that
but again i think their defense is
overlooked a little bit and i think once
they get the pieces back and they're
finally healthy
things are going to probably start
turning in the right direction if they
can
beat the bengals on saturday maybe
they're going to get a little bit more
respect but we'll have to wait and see
yeah they'll get to host an afc
championship if that were to play out so
let's hope for the best down there a lot
of good things great coverage this year
kale it's been fun to watch fellow coug
get some have that success down there so
thanks for coming on the show appreciate
you being a part of it hey thanks ryan
thanks guys appreciate it thanks kayla
take care kayla anderson everybody hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here